okay think I did
it my channel is sponsored by V one
which we'll
have is it
live yes my gosh we did
it
think do it go
home it
worked okay I haven't done this in a
really long time but
um twitch changed some
terms uh for live streaming um so now
you can
multistream so I will be streaming
conferences like stuff like this we're
going to do the Xbox partner stream
today um Again on YouTube
and on Twitch which is super cool uh I'm
going to make more of an effort to make
sure that I do them um at the time it's
just really hard because I have a
job I'm sorry about the whole job thing
uh but today we are catching up on the
Xbox partner
preview
um I have not had anything spoiled for
me so please no spoils it's only 28
minutes this is going to be my lunch
break for
today and I have been having some Tech
issues
so most of them should be fixed tomorrow
um but let's take a look shall we I'm
really really excited I love these like
kind of little updates that aren't like
super overhyped you just get to see some
cool fun stuff so let's do it let me
know if the audio is
okay it's currently
silent okay we need to fix
that it's not
muted
oh I just jumped the gun my
bad let's go I have no
expectations Yakuza sorry I mean like a
dragon Yakuza fans are living these days
so many new games all the
time infinite wealth looks awesome
what is this like DLC for infinite
wealth where you ride dolphins what is
[Music]
happening too many Street punks getting
you down time for the getaway you
deserve
Dono island is the destination for you
it's like
a a chill yaku spin what welcome to your
vacation within a vacation where a cozy
DIY lifestyle
awaits gather material yaku Animal
Crossing you're
joking buy unique Furniture oh my
gosh
or simply craft it
[Music]
yourself if these animations are
actually in this game he is okay I this
is nuts I was not I would never have
even put this on a bingo card let me
tell you a a thing about the like a
dragon SL Yakuza
series that they nail tone which I think
in my opinion is like good game
Direction More Than almost any any other
Studio on the planet like the fact that
you can have this and it makes sense and
it's still got the silly Vibe but they
also have really serious themes you're
dealing with like in someone in a Yakuza
G went blind because they were assaulted
and it caused them so much trauma and it
doesn't like make that a joke it's just
a thing that happened alongside the
random phone sex mini game
like what what a franchise to get to
work on it's amazing watch as your dream
home unfolds just the way you like it oh
oh my
God I can't believe this is
real is it
multiplayer in fact you can customize
the whole island to your heart's
content
[Music]
wow make friends with memorable
characters is your Island
PC
yeah okay I guess why
not develop your Island to accomodate
all kinds of
tourists and give them the time of their
lives oh my God thank you must
my what's the name of the dog in in uh
animal CR what's his name but beware of
certain un purple
you have to beat some sense into them to
preserve your Island
Kingdom wow explore nature
swim what oh my God I have so many
questions yes KK slid it thank you build
infrastructure I watch Liverpool game I
did Sky interact
others and develop your own resort
island your way I don't I don't know if
I want to play this
maybe um but I am so pleasantly
surprised
amazed oh my
god
wow the franchise just keeps on giving
man we don't deserve
it
cool don't want to play it but want to
see people play it yeah I could get
behind that maybe I don't know I might
want to see I'm not
sure you have my
attention
not
[Music]
I
got I got very distracted by the power
wash simulator logo which this clearly
is
not
looks like sort of high five
rushy but it's obviously not it's like
ghost run of me high five
rush I don't think I've heard of it aara
will not die I mean that looks sick is
this going to be one of those out
today
no looks
cool it's power wash Sim
too
ah yes stop Hill
DLC
[Music]
cool nice
nice blocks and video games are so
useless just kick them right
off
J
I'm getting like kind of condemned
Vibes like especially now which is
awesome Christ what the
[__] is it Shrek do you play as Shrek
new Shrek game
can to jump out of the water is such a
good opportunity for a jump scare like
I'll never forgive um fear it's like
fear one or two for having a jump scare
when you turned around to go down a
ladder was the
worst
I guess he's taking a nap so this is
some sort of stealth game c
themed my screen is way too big oh is it
like my webcam
sorry I make that mistake often because
um I have a really whooped
perspective because my
um monitor so
[Music]
huge uh that looked
cool it seems there will be trouble rub
cop let's [__] dangerous new guy in
town to have his ey on doing business in
Old Detroit every gang in the city more
the finsing their servic I played the
finals but I was just so bad at it party
goes on we need to find it like I really
just sucked at it I'm sure I'll try
again vultures are the biggest in
Detroit I'm planning to have a Robocop
video up next week my
partner I think this game looks
awesome such as meeting the new guy
tonight at the old slaughter house can
hear music we're getting close
definitely he emotion you play as part
with though maybe Justice never
sleeps
I'm not playing any more games after him
I have a large very very
fun I ain't scared of you I'm pumped up
with nuke like a freaking power plant R
get ready for a
meltdown what's that
noise I love
you you just got to find a staircase
RoboCop it's
fine you now have five seconds to
[Music]
comply it looks so good way better than
it has any right
to he really does have luscious lips huh
very
kissable hi I'm Philip Cy technical
director on dungeons of hinterberg and
I'm Risinger art director on dungeons of
hinterberg I know a lot of you have been
asking to see more of the social aspects
of hinterberg and how the people you
hang out with can help you as you
progress through the game so we're
excited to give you a better look in
this short trailer we will give you a
glimpse at how you might spend a typic
day in dungeons of hind decide which
Overworld to travel to spend the day
slaying and puzzling in a dungeon and
then head back to the Village to
befriend someone who may be the key to
your
success
looks very cozy German
game but if they hadn't said it had
combat I would not have guessed based on
the way this
[Music]
looks why
not that another portal it is a another
portal
[Music]
[Applause]
it's very hard to say if I'm into this
one up the music sounds very
cool and I like the
balance but I'm
unsure oh it's like Persona
[Music]
style that's smart
maybe I don't know not sure I'd like to
see more of the
[Music]
combat
do dungeons in between hookups that's
only what it looks
like were I was I at TC Vegas I was
[Music]
yes same bro relatable cool
wings
oh it's a fox game Fox and bird
[Music]
game
okay because it's giving me tunic
Vibes this could be my
jam which by the way I think tunic has
made it into my top 10 games I me tunic
is so good yeah meets death door you can
see some death door in it too for sure
if this is
got difficult
combat into
it oh it's a
sequel I don't think I'd even heard of
the first
one real banjo Kazi energy you're not
wrong thank God I was right that was a
it says it was a new game reveal like
this looks pretty rad never heard of
[Music]
it Spirit than not two is also new game
reveal does also have R Vibes yeah it
looks that looks like my I I just love
the genre of like tunic death door love
those kind of games or's up there
too well hello there you have my
attention my my
my
I mean it does look pry that was a weird
cut this is a weird trailer so far
[Applause]
[Music]
though I think I'm going to play through
the metal G solid
collection as well just cuz it's been
like
it's been like 20 years since I played
Metal Gear Solid one look this is a
weird trailer I don't know how well I
trust them to do it well especially
considering the tech issues with
collection volume one um it looks so
realistic because of under Engine 5 I'm
still excited though you'll get me with
Nostalgia pretty much no matter
what we'll
see you have been chosen to govern a
land of great peril will and
promise it has suffered long from the
scourge of banditry but there is another
threat an illegitimate Baron who claims
the Northern Territories as his own will
you prove yourself worthy of this honor
or will you perish by the traitor's
[Music]
steel not my kind of game looks cool
though used to play a lot of Age of
Empires back in the day otherwise I'm
just very very
bad at of this just
not I just make poor decisions and then
really fret over them a lot you
[Music]
know this does look really cool
though
[Music]
that was super addictive
well really wish I like this kind of
game just not for me kind of same
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
make poor decisions of as my whole life
SED up relatable
bro join what is this game called Mana
Lords you joined at the right
time it's going to be so hard to title
games like
this it does look very cool just not
really my thing which is
okay I like that they're doing this with
the Koko codes you can just like go get
more info if you want to for anything
you're particularly interested in I
think it's a good
idea finals
yeah welcome to the finals the world's
greatest game show I'm sure I will
stream more of it again I was just so
bad
at for the
match excited for the bluey Game Dude me
too
unironically
[Applause]
hyped the Chas is on they need to
deposit that cash they sure
doe gambo that's not a going to be a
game changer for sure dude industry will
never recover there's one that cash out
will take time to complete maybe they
can destroy their way out of trouble
here what a mo no doubt about it Scotty
we've got strategies in play yeah I do
think this game is super impressive um
again when I played it I was already
like 2 days late and jumped right in
with people have been playing for a
minute and just I just did not know what
the [__] I was
doing but I'm sure I
[Applause]
will
it's super impressive it's got a lot
going
[Music]
on it's a good trailer
too Titan full movement it totally does
have Titan full
movement not quite as extensive but it's
not far off it's very
cool it's it is just so video game you
know some sometimes the video game is
just so video game and it's one of
those it does have X Battlefield DS yeah
[Music]
yeah oh
AR got to
be is been diesel in
[Music]
it got to give the people what they want
Vin VIN Vin
VIN it's all every everybody the whole
fan Community you know they would just
like I just want B diesel please and
they were like hey we
listened you got
it it does look like such an improvement
gra at least
[Music]
pretty want another T Rock game dude I
used to love Turok Good
Times
it's like keeps giving me Far Cry 3
Vibes for some
reason something about the lighting
[Music]
maybe obviously it's
AR my fear is is it just AR but pretty I
mean probably but is that so bad like
I'm sure they have some updates but AR
is already pretty well feature
complete like I don't think it needs too
much more it's one of those like if an a
brn fix it you know I'm sure it'll have
some some changes
but it's just the ue5 upgrade of the
first one oh is it it's literally the
same
game the killer left the heart next to
the body oh Alan Wake this wasn't some
random act of violence this was so
excited to play this I did not get a
code we we playing it next week I'll
probably play it on Halloween a page of
text written with a
typew someone's been watching
us how do you run from an
idea from a story that lives in your
head I'm so excited dude I need to
escape this
nightmare
wake says a story will change reality
around
us and it's like I love it I think um so
I did get to see this game at um summer
game Fest like behind closed doors and I
got invited to a preview event but
couldn't go cuz it dur my work hours um
remedy done such a good job of just like
taking the core of what has made all of
their games good and add it all to Alan
Wake too like these visual effects that
we're seeing here are obviously very
control but they do this really like I I
was so impressed by it even though it's
in theory so simple it's a really good
job of like layering environments so you
can still clearly see where you're going
even if you're walking through like a
woods but you're maybe learning
something about a city and they kind of
layer the two on top of each other so
you're seeing both at once but the path
is still really
clear they just like have done such a
good job iterating on their own
successes in a way that I'm like super
impressed by the only thing that I
really didn't like about it um and I'm
hoping that it's justified by the
story is this character I don't remember
what her name is um I really didn't like
her performance very much like I found
it
distracting and I'm hoping that that is
because she is a character that Alan has
written and th she's a little like like
she's not a real person Saga
um because it definitely stood out to me
so maybe that will be explained
otherwise she definitely clearly to me
was not American as well like it was she
was either Australian or English and
that stood out to me too but yeah I
don't know I don't know but because I
think she's a character that Alan
created that
maybe ran into the
story the delivery was just like a
little show me the terror show
me it sounded like somebody reading a
book and like what a goddamn jump from
the first
game see what I mean like that line I
think is a really good example of what
I'm saying she just goes FBI drop the
knife you
know um but yeah like like the
animation's so good the visual effects
like I just it's wild if you watch Alan
win next to Alan win 2 footage looks so
good
I'm super excited to play
it sounds like an actress reading a
script yeah but maybe it's meant to is
my
[Music]
point hopefully it's meant
to also great song Choice here can't
wait dude it's the game that I'm
currently most excited about I will
stream it it comes out tomorrow can I
stream it tomorrow yeah yeah yeah yeah
we can do it we can stream it
tomorrow it'll make that happen so I'm
going to do the first hours on YouTube
again and then we'll do um the page will
open the overlap or is the page it am I
just playing into the
story I'm going to [__] myself dude I'm
such a baby I got so
scared
what water pressed in on the out of the
question I feel like I got so creative
with
it the great enemy design oh animation
like I'm
just I hope that my hype is delivered
upon I think reviews came out today
um it just it just looks so [__]
remedy you know like it just remedy on
crap which I love she can't see me in
the
light where is
she Restless
dreams
Restless
it's like almost pitch
black
darkness this is got to be a boss
fight
God I'm going to be so
scared
the song will show me the
[Music]
way this game was a good recap of one
cuz I never finished
it I don't know that you'll need
it the visual effects dude I love it
it's like they were just like at the
we're a video game [__] it like just
made it here we go again I'm just I love
it I'm so enthusiastic about their
design
obviously like I'm a fan of video games
being video games and not pretending to
be films and like this is such a good
example of that you know what I mean
sorry I'm just repeating myself but it's
how I
[Music]
feel wonder how linear the game ends up
being I expect it to be super
linear
so this was fun couple of things I did
not
[Music]
expect yeah this is fun like this is uh
well that's not what it's called it was
the the island thing looks absolutely
nuts interested in both of these to be
honest rocop can't wait Game of the Year
unsure about this I'd want to see more
of the combat unsure about this would
want to see more combat also unsure
about this just because I have trust
issues the finals looks rad as hell Mana
Lords not my kind of game looks good
though o surv survival is ended which
great Allan Wake to very hyped so it's
like was pretty chill had a good time
nothing to blow you away there but they
weren't pretending that it was going to
do that
so you
know I'm assuming that that's
[Music]
it it was fun
it's like a nice
little event the finals open Beta
started today did it good to know I
should jump in and play more of it um so
before we head off I did also want to
watch the squadrons
42 trailer before I get back to
work Squadron 42 what is it called Just
Like official gameplay overview this one
here oh that's pretty long though it's
another 26 minutes can I get away with
that nah it's too long
damn it I got to eat you know thank you
21 pile piles of uh sh um so I'll try
and check that out on stream later
because I would really like to watch
over that
too it's so nuts that their first
cinematic teaser released 5 years ago
man I don't know how they get away with
it it's wild uh yeah thank you for
watching Everybody obviously the chat
here has to stay just twitch chat for
everybody watching on YouTube that's a
term of twitch's service is you can't
show the YouTube chat on screen but
obviously I can still see both that's
why I'm responding to both um I'm going
to do these streams on YouTube for
conferences which I'm excited about
they'll be on both but um that way they
just stay up on YouTube as well which
I'm happy about and going to do the
first hours as streams
um just for big releases really but
we'll just keep the first hour on on
YouTube and then do the rest of it on
Twitch and then the rest will go on the
separate VOD Channel I'll figure it out
but that's that's the idea um but
definitely conference reactions and I'll
do as many of them live as I can get
away
with um thank you for hanging
out I gonna
raid well Bruce is playing Survival
ascended so twitch let's go raid Bruce
you can see that
game and hoping to stream Allan Wake to
tomorrow we'll see how it goes thanks
for hanging out everybody I hope you're
all having a lovely lunch break too if
that's what it's that what you doing I
don't know what you're doing I had a
good
time all
right bye
everybody